that's how about storks at the summit
working with cool people on storks you
got to work with I think one of the
actors with the greatest voices yeah in
the medium mr. Kelsey Grammer - Kelsey I
worked with him years ago and man what
an amazing voice he has yeah he's he's
the best he's got that gravitas and you
know for me it was it was cool cuz
obviously I'm a huge Simpsons head
mm-hmm and there were times yeah you
know a few times when he was like doing
his vocal warm-ups and stuff you'd sort
of drop into Sideshow Bob oh he would
yeah and actually I think I'm pretty
sure we have a picture of Sideshow Bob
right yeah there yeah yeah so yeah we'd
be recording and he would you know do a
little bit of that you know and my brain
would just go crazy you know I'm
actually I'm pretty sure I have a
picture of my brain going crazy - the
red parts the crazy part so wait a
minute so yet you hear him doing
Sideshow Bob and you're such a Simpsons
fan you go crazy
anything you do have that effect on
people you think maybe like maybe dick
in a box
it's tough because I can't really
perform it for people the way he can so
that that makes me kind of angry and
actually I think I have a picture of me
looking angry well you shouldn't be I
mean I love digging a box yeah well you
saying that actually makes me feel
really happy in fact I think I have a
picture of you guys know what they say a
picture is worth a thousand words and
speaking of a thousand words I'd
appreciate have a picture of a
dictionary right it's just like the old
saying you can't dress a monkey up like
Jack Sparrow with this tongue sticking
out pretty sure we do have a picture of
Mike
that was worth it when you said that I
was so hoping you had that photo
you